[Music]
it begins
with a seemingly simple innocent idea
[Applause]
[Music]
that thinking positive will bring about
positive experiences into one's life
with mainstream promotion of the idea
with celebrities promoting it
entire careers based around teaching it
surely there's merit
to the law of attraction but the further
you go down that rabbit hole
the less innocent things become i i had
friends
that were telling me that the secret is
real law of attraction
manifestation how to effectively
manifest
your dream life
it's an idea heavily promoted by
self-help communities
an idea that some become completely
identified with
the law of attraction is no longer a
fringe concept
it very much has successfully
infiltrated the mainstream
in this two-part series i'll be
investigating the law of attraction
as both an idea and the profitable
industry behind it
because what begins as an innocent idea
that most can get behind
quickly turns into a tool for
gaslighting cult
and material harm
[Music]
this video was helped made possible by
our sponsor
trends which to those of you who are
interested in entrepreneurship
running your own business or just
genuinely want to inform yourself on
these things are going to love
because with a trend subscription you
gain access to an
ultimate knowledge hub and a community
of industry thought leaders in virtually
every field
trends is a part of the hustle which is
a daily business and technology
newsletter that's read by a million
users a day
and with trends you get a first look at
emerging markets which is great if
you're looking for a new business
venture to pursue but don't know where
to start and whether it will be viable
enough
you also get exclusive access to their
content library which includes weekly
lectures
from experts who teach things like
growth strategies seo or how to send the
perfect cold email
and if that wasn't enough trends also
gives you the opportunity to workshop
your ideas and network with other
entrepreneurs and investors
so if that sounds like something you'd
be interested in join the trends
community today and get your first seven
days for just one dollar by going to
trends dot co
forward slash james janney the link will
also be in the description below
but with that being said let's dive
right back into the video
it's important that before we fully
begin to understand the problems with
the law of attraction
we understand what its fundamental
claims and beliefs are
and so allow me to give you an overview
as unbiased as i can possibly be
everything in the universe is energy
moving and vibrating on their own
frequencies
and so too are our thoughts and feelings
whatever frequency your thoughts and
feelings are vibrating at
you will attract that of which is
vibrating on the same frequency
just like tuning into a radio station
where when tuned to a certain frequency
we can hear only the songs that are
being played on that frequency
your life is much the same when you set
your intentions into the universe and
you begin to think
and feel on the same vibrations as that
of which you desire it is that of which
vibrates on the same frequency that you
will attract and manifest
into your life whether it's wealth
happiness or relationships it is by
thinking
and feeling as though these things are
already yours that you will begin
attracting these things into your life
you've done it yourself remember those
moments where you had a goal
or set intention in mind and seemingly
out of nowhere the right person appeared
at the right time and place that helped
you inch closer to or achieve that goal
when things just seemingly aligned in
the universe where random occurrences
like
meeting your best friend by chance
couldn't just be explained by luck alone
the truth is you manifested these things
into your life
isn't that a powerful thing to know that
by aligning your thoughts and feelings
to that of which you want
you can manifest and make those things a
reality and just as positive thoughts
and feelings attract positive
manifestations towards you
so too will negative thoughts and
feelings when your predominant thoughts
and feelings are of debt relationship
issues and negativity you will attract
those things into your life
the truth is that you can change your
reality by changing your thoughts and
feelings
the world is abundant abundant with joy
love and peace align your thinking and
your feeling
with that abundance leave the clutches
of scarcity thinking
and your life too will be filled with
[Music]
abundance
[Music]
before we tackle this idea and the
problems it creates
it's first important to understand what
makes it so alluring
positive thinking the idea that you can
change your life circumstances by
changing your thoughts and your feelings
visualizing those goals that you have
for yourself truly being able to see
clearly what it is that you want from
life
these things are not necessarily bad
it's important before we continue that
we make this distinction
positive thinking having set goals
visualizations
affirmations meditating they all have
their own place
but that isn't what i'm talking about
here the law of attraction
takes these things and adds an element
of spirituality to it all
for some of you the law of attraction
already comes off as absurd
but understand that its popularity and
the money that flows in this industry is
eye-watering
when you have people making so much
money off something like this
then it's worth investigating the
ideologies these individuals promote
don't you think because at the heart of
this all lies a bigger problem
a problem that underpins self-help gurus
new age spirituality
and success itself to those of you that
already believe in the law of attraction
or things of that nature and are not
willing to have your belief
questioned or criticized then i would
advise not continuing
my only question now is how willing are
you to follow me down this rabbit hole
the law of attraction has a central
claim to its belief
that your thoughts and feelings vibrate
on a frequency and that this vibration
is able to quote
attract vibrations of a similar
frequency
the burden of proof then falls on loa
believers to show that such a statement
is true
so is it after all wasn't it einstein
who said
everything is energy and that's all
there is to it match the frequency of
the reality you want and you cannot help
but get that reality
it can be no other way this is not
philosophy this is
physics except you never did
despite the quote being cited amongst
law of attraction believers
these words were never actually uttered
by einstein although just a small
example
this subtle deceit and distortion of the
facts seems to be a recurring theme the
more you dive into the law of attraction
pseudoscience consists of statements
beliefs or practices that try to claim
legitimate bearings in science using
words like
law or vague references to quantum
science to make it sound valid
of course pseudoscience specifically
fails to comply with the scientific
method which is what turns it into
pseudoscience in the first place
it cannot be proven but deceit can be
rather easy in the age of the internet
a quick google search of do your
thoughts and feelings have a frequency
will produce an answer box that states
every thought and emotion has its own
vibrational frequency or wavelength the
title of this article
is the quantum mechanics of changing
thoughts but if one was to investigate
further
we see that the article was written by
quote dr kim and dr hill
who are both authors of the site itself
on their site they state that quote
together they have
over 20 qualifications in holistic
modalities including biofeedback
neuro-linguistic programming tibetan
buddhism psychology
hypnosis energy psychology coaching
visualization
and meditation note however the lack of
a scientific background
more specifically the lack of any
qualifications in physics and quantum
physics
when looking back at the original
article we see that it is filled with
assumptions and easily falsifiable
claims
the original article also contains a
sub-link to another article
titled quote quantum mechanics and your
authentic potential
in this article they make reference to a
study by dr
masuru imoto emoto's study is commonly
cited when attempting to prove the
scientific basis for the law of
attraction or the idea that thoughts and
feelings are able to affect the physical
world
emoto claimed that our emotional
energies and vibrations could change the
physical structure of water his
experiments consisted of
exposing water in glasses to different
words pictures or music
and then freezing and examining the
crystals that formed emoto claimed his
experiments showed that water exposed to
positive speech and thoughts would
result in visually pleasing crystals
being formed when the water was frozen
and that negative thoughts and
intentions would yield to ugly
frozen crystal formations emoto's
original double-blind study of this
experiment
included co-researchers dean radin gail
hayson
and takashige kizu the study was then
published in the journal
explore the journal of science and
healing so
was emoto really onto something once
more a level of deceit lies beyond the
surface
dean raddin a participant in a moto
study is also the co-editor in chief of
the journal
explore the journal of science and
healing the very same journal that the
studies were published in
and explore has been heavily criticized
by the scientific community for the
content it publishes
described as a quote sham masquerading
as a real scientific journal
emoto's initial double-blind study was
in fact badly carried out and when a
follow-up triple study was conducted to
repeat the test it showed an even less
significant outcome and acknowledged the
difficulties of properly controlling the
experiment
dr emoto himself is technically not a
doctor he is a doctor of
alternative medicine at the open
international university for alternative
medicine in india
a quote university that specifically
targeted quacks and sold them fake
degrees
emoto was also personally invited to
take the 1 million
paranormal challenge by james randy a
challenge that promised to pay out 1
million us dollars to anyone that could
demonstrate a supernormal or paranormal
ability
under agreed-upon scientific testing
criteria emoto
did not participate
once more a prevailing theme around the
supposed science of the law of
attraction
are controversies criticisms and deceit
with obscure references to quantum
physics or brainwaves from individuals
that are seemingly unqualified to talk
on the subject
it isn't a surprise that the law of
attraction is considered a pseudoscience
and isn't taken seriously in any form of
mainstream science
to the average person references to
these scientific terms often go
unchecked and unverified
because whoever is informing you sounds
like a figure of authority on the
subject by virtue of just mentioning
words like
quantum and that's the point isn't it
because the issues with the law of
attraction doesn't stop at the science
even if we cannot prove its existence
through the scientific method
there remains fundamental flaws in its
promoted ideology
floors that lay the land for people with
questionable intentions
there is a fundamental problem with the
law of attraction
suppose you were to ask me the question
james why don't you actually attempt to
give the law of attraction a try for
yourself
as opposed to just listening to the
criticisms and science
why don't you give visualizations
affirmations
thinking on the level of that of which
you would like to attract into your life
a chance and suppose i truly did go
through this idea
for a week for a month a year or even a
decade
two scenarios may occur either i
manifest that of which i wanted into my
life
or i don't which in and of itself can be
subjective
let's assume that i don't receive from
the universe that of which i wanted to
attract i then come back to you years
later and tell you of my
findings what do you suppose if you were
a believer in the law of attraction
your response would be the reason the
loa is not working
is because you don't believe it works
what's holding you back
is a subconscious resistance or blockage
or barrier
you are really really weighing your
energy down with a ton of resistance
you are manifesting probably the absence
of something you want
it is crucial to brainwash
that subconscious to wipe away that
negativity
and herein lies the problem the law of
attraction is
at its core unfalsifiable and
unfalsifiable claims or ideas pave the
way for those who have bad intentions
because if i were to sell you a course a
program or a book promoting an
unfalsifiable claim
i am left completely and utterly
blameless isn't that just convenient
the second part of this series will
expand on this idea further
i'm aware that to those of you that
truly do believe in the law of
attraction
your convictions may remain unwavering
how could it be wrong
what could possibly explain those events
in which my thoughts and feelings were
so aligned that i genuinely manifested
that of which i was looking for
how can anything explain those constant
coincidences
everything i wrote on this piece of
paper has come
true but when coincidences are
that specific and that they happen that
often
you have to stop questioning things what
about the celebrities and the successful
people that credit the law of attraction
to their success
they can't be lying they genuinely do
use the law of attraction themselves
jim carrey will smith oprah winfrey
russell brand conor mcgregor
jay-z arnold schwarzenegger steve harvey
and the list goes on
survivorship bias is a logical error
made when you concentrate on the people
or things that made it past some
selection process
and begin to overlook those that did not
sure
there are some famous and successful
people that credit the law of attraction
to their success
but what about the 99 of those who also
believe
in the law of attraction but failed to
get anywhere near that level of success
in their lives
conveniently we can lay out a bunch of
justifications as to why they didn't
achieve the same level of success
but surely a more rational and truthful
approach would be to look at these
people's success as a multifaceted
answer that these individuals may have
been stating their intentions into the
world visualizing their goals
affirming themselves but none of these
things were necessarily the road map
that paved their success that there are
elements of luck
talent upbringing hard work and
countless other factors at play here
why make that logical leap into assuming
the law of attraction
is the explanation confirmation bias
also seems to be rampant here
because while someone like conor
mcgregor is a firm believer in the law
of attraction
we seem to look at his successful wins
and fights and completely ignore the
losses
did mcgregor also manifest his losing
fight against khabib
of course the law of attraction may
suggest that such a loss was necessary
for mcgregor to manifest success in the
future or that mcgregor wasn't truly
aligning his thoughts and feelings with
his intentions
the answer of course could never simply
be that the law of attraction doesn't
exist
that the reasons for mcgregor's loss are
to do with countless other variables
but what about those moments where you
truly did set your focus on something
and seemingly coincidental occurrences
or opportunities appeared out of nowhere
that specific and that they happen that
often
you have to stop questioning things
the beta meinhof phenomenon is an effect
that arises when your awareness of
something increases
usually when you notice something new
and suddenly you're aware of that thing
all over the place it's sometimes
referred to as blue or red cast syndrome
after those who claim to notice blue or
red cars everywhere all of a sudden
after purchasing their own
even though nothing in reality has
changed take
for example an apple let me ask you
while watching this video how many
instances did you notice the image of an
apple
or the word apple how about you take
another look
[Music]
[Music]
law of attraction believers may however
cite something like the beta minor
phenomenon
as proof that their thoughts and
feelings are able to manifest or attract
that of which you desired but you didn't
really desire or set the intentions into
the universe of wanting to see apples
did you it seems like much of the law of
attraction world applies motivated
reasoning to their logic
they start with a conclusion and work
their way backwards attempting to find
anything that they could use to justify
it
whilst throwing away any evidence of the
contrary
now imagine combining all of these
biases with the fact that many turn the
law of attraction into an actual
identity and a core belief system
combine the emotional and financial
investment people place into such a
belief
and it becomes abundantly clear of
course you want to believe in the law of
attraction when you have invested so
much into it
of course you're not going to be willing
to find a way in which you could
possibly be wrong or willing to accept
that you're wrong
so that leaves us with one last rebuke
what's the problem here james
why not let people believe in the law of
attraction it's doing them no harm after
all
right if this were true then this video
would likely not have been made
the only problem is it isn't
[Music]
it may be hard to spot the red flags
initially
because after all the concept begins
with something that sounds like a
truthful statement
thing can feel positive and you will
attract positive
but remember the inverse applies to this
too
that thinking and feeling on a quote
negative vibration will also attract
negative manifestations into your life
we can likely all agree that it's best
to think positively or that optimism has
its place in living a happier life
but we would never expect someone to be
feeling great all the time
or at least we would never try to place
that burden on someone else
we understand that it's okay to feel bad
and guilting ourselves for feeling this
way doesn't seem to be practical nor
does it seem healthy
but consider emotions and thoughts
through the lens of an individual who
believes in the law of attraction
why do you feel low why is that is it
because you were vibrating on a negative
frequency
when your day doesn't seem to be going
well why is that
is it because you were the one that
manifested these things
if you haven't achieved your goals yet
is it because of your own failure to be
thinking and feeling on the same
frequency
as that of which you are trying to
attract into your life
underpinning much of the law of
attraction community is this notion of
blame
that when things haven't gone your way
at the heart of it
you are to blame and no matter how hard
someone may argue that the law of
attraction doesn't suggest you should
feel guilty when you are quote vibrating
on a lower frequency
the very idea that you are at fault is a
fundamental premise in the law of
attraction
when you have an unfalsifiable belief
like this you quite literally begin to
gaslight yourself
because behind everything that happens
to you or your surroundings is that
recurring question
did i manifest this into my life
how willing then would you be as a
believer on the law of attraction
to embrace negative emotions how willing
would you be to accept a bout of
depression
how willing would you be to suppress
such emotions or thoughts on the basis
that they'll ruin your quote
vibe imagine the psychological harm that
a belief system like this could cause
and the level of paranoia that entails
it
the law of attraction enables itself to
be a blameless entity
where all blame falls on its believers
is it a surprise then when i tell you
that it makes appearances in countless
multi-level marketing companies how to
succeed in
mlm using law of attraction is it a
surprise that the law of attraction is
designed perfectly for cult-like
thinking
because once more any critical thinking
or doubts you have
are encouraged to be suppressed don't
believe
it works what's holding you back is a
subconscious resistance or blockage or
barrier you are really really
weighing your energy down with a ton of
resistance you are manifesting
probably the absence of something you
want it is crucial
to brainwash that subconscious
any failure to reach the goals required
by a cult or multi-level marketing
company
falls not at the feet of the company but
at your very own
it's here where material harm in the law
of attraction begins to show
but it doesn't stop here either because
the law of attraction
extrapolates itself into the world of
medicine and health
too where it claims that disease and
illness can be blamed on your very own
vibrations
in ronda byrne's film the secret a film
that popularized the law of attraction
at the mainstream level
there are several examples and quotes
that allude to the fact that disease
like
cancer can be cured through the idea of
positive thinking
it is here where material harm surpasses
psychological barriers and leads its way
into fatal consequences
it is here where something that
initially sounds so harmless
takes a darker more serious turn
positive thinking and optimism
visualizing your goals
affirmations meditation are all on the
surface level
reasonable and arguably beneficial
habits but is it possible to strip these
things away from the law of attraction
along with any pseudoscience that comes
with it
is it possible to view these things on
their own and to see them for what they
are
not a road map to success or a secret to
winning the game of life
but a helpful tool if so then there is
one question that seemingly remains
when we look at the law of attraction
who is it that stands to gain off of
something like this
who benefits from being blameless who
are the real winners of this ideology
because make no mistake this
is no small business
i i had friends that were telling me
that the secret is real
there's this cult around napoleon hill
but in reality he was just a scam artist
but what you don't realize is they are
[Music]
you know that's how good these guys are
vemma and law of attraction basically go
hand in hand
you gotta break through the logic
you cannot let logic control you
logic is is is bad for us
how much money did you lose in your
experience
oh no the cost of ten thousand pounds
[Music]
because i know i was absolutely broken
um it's the only way i could put in the
words i was broken
because of my experience
[Music]
hello my friends and just before you
click off the video i wanted to say
thank you so much for watching to the
end this is the first part of a two-part
series that i'm doing
so be sure to hit the subscribe button
along with a notification bell turned on
so that you're notified
when the next part will be uploaded and
if you're watching this a little bit
later i'll be sure to have the second
episode linked in the description below
and of course be sure to check out
trends and sign up today to get your
first
seven days for just one dollar they
really do help out with sponsoring these
videos
this series is potentially one of the
most controversial that i've done so it
goes without saying again that if
there's anyone that i bring up either
directly or indirectly
that doesn't mean i'm calling them a
scammer or whatever or i'm not inciting
any kind of harassment
towards that person so please of course
do not do that look at this series as
almost another warning or another
perspective to everything
and if you did enjoy this first part of
the series then do be sure to hit the
like button i know these call to actions
can be a little bit annoying but it
really does help and it's totally free
and if you would like to support the
channel further i do have a patreon
where i post things like q and a's i'm
doing now monthly video editing
tutorials
and some other exciting stuff on there
so if that sounds like something you'd
be interested in do check it out i've
got a link for that in the description
as well i hope to see you all in the
second part of this series
things are going to be getting really
really interesting so be sure not to
miss out on it but with that being said
i wish you all the best rest of the day
wherever you are
as always hunter
[Music]
so many moments put aside
getting out alive
getting out of line
writing letters in the sand
lost